Alice uh finally somebody stopped you
but also from our team uh Happy Birthday
Alice congratulations you're 14 right
now do you feel old
yet yeah I mean like it's like I'm a
year older than I was yesterday but yeah
I mean uh I'm happy I guess I didn't
lose today although I feel like I was
probably better at some point in the
game tell us about uh today's game
critical
moments um yeah so out of the opening I
think I'm not sure like whether I played
it correctly with like A6 and A5 I think
A6 was correct I'm not sure like maybe I
was supposed to wait till she played
Knight C4 before he played A5 but even
so I think the Knight should probably
still go to C4 um because like on B5 it
just doesn't really control the E5
Square um so like I saw Knight B5 with a
bit string and I was like happy once I
got a knight C5 and 94 and um and I knew
like I probably had to be better here um
but it wasn't
easy yeah I think uh okay like here
after p7 I was happy um Bishop D3 rookie
e uh Bishop E3 yeah I mean I consider
Knight G3 check and then uh Rook J D3
but I with worried about some Queen F2
um and uh yeah so there there was like
looking at Bishop takes B5 but um I
guess it was annoying for me because
when I calculated it originally I had
calculated it with uh I for some reason
missed Queen F2 so then when I started
calculating here I was like okay I'll go
for Queen d8 um so yeah after I played
Queen d8 okay uh in yeah here I mean I
thought this this was I was very happy
with but then I played like Queen E8
Queen d8 and that was not probably not
very smart of me um because I for some
reason I just like missed Bishop F4 so I
should have done something like um
instead of Queen da uh Queen I probably
should have done like Queen E7 um or R
uh R E8 because um yeah her pwns are
very weak and I have a feel just to
interrupt you for a second uh begim did
win her game uh with the black pieces
against Anna zansi a big result for the
standings a big result for one of well
for the moment the leader of the
tournament MH back to your game Alice oh
yeah okay so I mean yeah oh yeah here I
also consider bishy 5 I mean I knew I
had to be better in this position it's
just um so much easier for me to play
Bish 5 and then I have some pretty nice
attack um going on in the king side yeah
um yeah but Queen E8 Queen d8 wasn't
very good
um and when did you feel like she
finally proved uh her defensive skills
and you ready to accept the fact that
this one is going to end into a draw
yeah I mean after Queen E1 I like okay I
probably don't have anything and I don't
really want to over press um yeah so
then it was just a draw I
mean still the streak had to end at some
point uh it ended up on I would say a
positive note with a black pieces
against a very tough opponent a draw is
not a bad result uh we'll let you go
enjoy your rest day and we'll see you in
a couple of uh
days thank you whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa Alice what what what's the
fade of the
cupcake very curious are we sharing you
and I together your cupcake uh your
birthday
cupcake uh sorry the cupcake the the the
the cake next to your board I'm asking
are we
sharing we could we could we can did she
say we can she said we could we could
well turn that into to a promise and we
got a deal don't try to steal the
birthday cake yes sir the cupcake it
look really good oh my goodness Alice
enjoy your rest day good luck in the
remainder of the
tournament right thank you all right uh